First off, transactional middleware, recall that we have to
deal with reliability and those acid requirements. Various approaches including
two-phased commit are policies which the application
can obey in order to get higher reliability and guaranteed consistency.
We'd like to develop a transactional middleware solutions in such a way that we
have location transparency. That is, the pieces the server
doesn't know where the clients are distributed. And moreover, the clients don't
know where the server is other than possibly with some kind of IP address for
the web server. Some of the products over the years that have been developed for
dealing with transactional middleware include CICS on IBM mainframes.
Tuxedo, which is a UNIX-based approach, and Encina, from Hewlett Packard.